I'm going to show you how to get rid of
bloating in your stomach very very fast
I've had bloating for many many years
and I didn't know what it was at the
time so I have firsthand experience on
bloating and not to mention I've worked
with tens of thousands of people over 35
years and many of these people had
bloating as a primary concern so I'm
going to show you exactly how to get rid
of your bloating and I'm going to make
it really simple there are things that
are really really important and there
are things that are very trivial and not
very important and those are usually on
like Wikipedia on the first few pages of
Google when you do searches on bloating
really it's just the same information
recycled over and over and over
medically they'll examine you they
diagnose you and then they treat you
with usually an over-the-counter
medication or some prescription
medication which is crazy because
anything going on with your digestive
system you must first look at the foods
that you're eating it's the foods okay
so here's a really simple thing you
should start out with when did the
bloating start what did I eat just
before that that will give you a big
clue and one of the problems that people
run into is that a lot of times they
don't just eat one thing they have a
combination of things it makes it a lot
more difficult so as you start to figure
out what's really behind this bloating I
think it's going to be very important to
eat uh lesser amounts of foods just like
maybe three different foods so you can
at least start isolating what's really
doing the most bloating versus this huge
long complex recipe also the more
frequent you eat the more bloating
problems you're gonna have our digestive
system is very long and many people keep
that huge tube completely filled all the
time with the snacks and three meals
Etc that's really hard on the system and
they never have a chance to fully digest
their food if you can Implement
intermittent fasting that alone will
greatly help you and and when we talk
about bloating we're talking about gas
usually and the gas is produced by
microbes
fermenting certain things like bread
that rises through the help of yeast
which is a microbe or you have beer or
champagne that has those bubbles okay
that's gas that's produced from microbes
so the microbes in your gut ferment
certain things that create gas and
usually the bloating is coming from some
type of problem with this interaction
between the microbe and their food and
the gas the primary source of food is
carbohydrates what is a carbohydrate
It's a combination of three things
sugars
starches
or fibers so what I want to emphasize in
fixing this bloating is it's way more
important
to avoid something than it is to add
something like a remedy like a different
food so let's dive into like the most
common foods you're going to have to
avoid and this is basically the low
hanging fruit and when I talk about
fruit I'm actually talking about fruit
is the number one thing that's probably
bloating you because in Fruit you have
the sugar you have the starch and you
have fiber so I'm sorry to tell you that
but
fruit is probably at the top of the list
and of course beans would be number two
and then we get grains as in the bread
pasta cereal crackers biscuits waffles
pancakes muffins
Etc and of course all the refined sugars
too like the table sugar the honey the
high fructose corn syrup and the sugar
alcohols that are in a lot of Keto
snacks boy they can really bloat you
sorbitol
Mannitol maltitol and even Xylitol and
erythritol because you really just want
to start reading ingredients so even now
they might be keto friendly they're not
bloating friendly or bloat friendly then
we get another type of carbohydrate like
starches that would be like rice potato
wheat corn fries and then you also have
these um
manufactured carbohydrates as in
maltodextrin or dextrin be careful those
those can really
um blow you big time and this is why
it's so important to read the
ingredients
there's also some other things that
you'll see in the common ingredients as
well are functional fibers these are
so-called healthy fibers that they're
creating if you like inulin some people
are not sensitive to it but some people
are guar gum xantham gum even like when
you eat oatmeal or oats you have this
thing that's considered heart healthy
beta-glucan that's a fiber so all of
these things are like those hidden
factors that can bloat you in a lot of
different foods that you eat and then we
get to the topic of
prebiotics right they put these
Prebiotic type fibers in a lot of
supplements and Shakes and superfoods
super green products
plant-based protein powders different
seeds agave nectar so prebiotics are
good for some people but other people
they're not very good and they can bloat
you and what I'm trying to do is I'm
trying to list the most common reasons
why people bloat so you can start
eliminating those and seeing if that's
your problem all right so that's number
one okay
number two this includes actual
allergies and sensitivities and
something else called intolerance
so you could have gluten intolerance
which is very very common
one thing about gluten It's A protein
that we cannot digest so it creates a
lot of problems in our guts and some
people that don't have a problem
actually do have a problem because many
times these proteins also stimulate an
opioid receptor it's kind of like
getting a little dosage of morphines and
that can numb any symptoms you have in
the gastrointestinal area thinking oh
I'm fine I can I can digest these fine
but you have all these other Associated
problems I have a very interesting video
on that but if you avoid just all the
grains you don't worry about gluten
because gluten is really only in grains
then you have lactose this is milk sugar
this is in Dairy if you're doing Dairy
that could be another reason and then
you have the protein in Dairy called
casein you can have an algae with that
as well and that can create bloating
also nuts if that can bloat you and of
course if you turn the nut into some
type of nut butter and you eat a lot of
it boy that can blow you as well number
three are actual vegetables now
vegetables are low in sugar they're low
in starch usually some aren't but I'm
talking about the leafy greens but
they're very high in fiber and if you
have
IBS irritable bowel syndrome or you have
small intestinal bacterial overgrowth
sibo
that means the microbes that should be
in the large intestine are in the wrong
place they're in the small intestine so
as soon as you start eating fiber
anything with fiber or like a Prebiotic
or even a probiotic Boy by the time it
hits your small intestine you bloat it's
a common problem uh the solution for
that I will put the link down below but
um the way that you identify that is
that you just blow it with all
vegetables and the remedy for that is
HCl hydrochloric acid and you can get
that in a supplement called betaine
hydrochloride but you're gonna have to
avoid vegetables for a while and go on
the carnivore diet but typically most
people are okay with vegetables and
they're going to be more okay with more
lettuce type of vegetables versus other
things for example broccoli I cannot
consume broccoli or I will bloat like a
balloon other people can do broccoli but
they can't do cabbage I can do cabbage
and I have no problem with that cabbage
has certain things in it that are
usually good for people with IBS or
irritable bowel syndrome in fact it's
probably one of the only vegetables that
they can eat that can help them
especially if they have a gastritis so
you want to play around with your
vegetable consumption and just take a
look at what happened right before you
started bloating was it a point where
you just ate a lot of vegetables or you
ate something else you just want to
isolate what it is number four stress
chronic stress especially stress
inhibits the parasympathetic nervous
system which is called the rest and
digest it's the the system that helps
you sleep it's the system that helps you
digest so the more stress you have the
less digestion you're going to have
and this is probably why some of the
recommendations out there with long
walks are really good with bloating it
doesn't really correct the problem
because you have to fix whatever's
stressing you out anything that reduces
stress can help your digestion and also
this is why vitamin B1 is really good
for people that have bloating with
stress I think the best way to describe
that scenario is let's say you wake up
and your stomach is flat but at the end
of the day it's bloated suspect more
stress than anything but it could be
food as well but in that case just take
more B1 and do whatever you can to
reduce stress number five constipation
can also cause bloating because your
your pipes are backed up you have a
plumbing problem and doing intermittent
fasting eating the right foods can
greatly help just taking a probiotic but
I think it's way more important to fix
the constipation than to worry about
some laxative and I'm talking about an
herbal laxative you can take Smooth Move
tea slippery elm bark is a real mild
form there's stronger versions of herbs
that you can take but it's very very
important never to have constipation
because that can really create issues
purified bile salts are a good way to
help lubricate the colon and bile salts
are interesting because your microbes
May make them and also bile salts
prevent sibo they help you break down
fats and the way that you know that
you're deficient in bile salts is not
only do you get bloating and
constipation but your stool will float
and it might even be lighter colored
okay so that just means that you're you
have more fat in the stool because you
don't have enough bile so you might want
to take bile salts after the meal
because they're alkaline if you take
them before the meal that can interrupt
with the acid in the stomach and also
the way that you know you took too much
bile salts is if you get diarrhea so you
want to just kind of figure out how much
you need menstrual cramps is another
reason why people bloat and if you think
about what a menstrual cramp is it's a
cramp okay and so what do you do for
cramps you take calcium magnesium so
just take some of that and that should
greatly help those cramps now I have
another digestive video that had over 7
million views if you haven't seen this
one check it out I put it up right here